what are the best ways for directors and
actors to unpack a screenplay
you know the first thing is that
you want to meet and talk with the actor
as a director
and before you cast them you hopefully
and um
and I'm talking about in terms of like
stars who are going to be made an offer
you're not going to chance to
necessarily audition them or but if
you're if you're dealing with a name
sort of actor you want to make sure you
can sit and talk with them and just know
you you're going to make the same movie
uh because it's really a bummer when you
get on the set and you realize this
actor sees it a whole other movie and
you may not win that battle because they
are oftentimes more important to the
studio than the directors are so
um so it's important to have the
dialogue going and just be sure like we
see this movie the same way and we feel
his character the same way
um so that that's an important thing and
most good actors will do their own
breakdowns used to be like well years
ago when I was getting started I used to
write biographies for every character
I'd written you know way into their
childhoods where I formed them I've
always been weeks and weeks and weeks
doing this they were given to the actor
and I would say look this is not a Bible
um this is just something for you to
reference and if there's something you
want to use great if not throw it away
and usually they were grateful sometimes
they were like yeah okay
but I've learned now that good actors
will do that already and they want to
bring their own thing to this
character's backstory they don't
necessarily want my take the writer's
take or the director's take they want to
find their own way into this character
the same way I have to find my own way
into a story
so unless it's something really critical
about that backstory that that informs
you know an important behavioral point
in the in the movie
um I don't do that anymore because I
know they're gonna They're Gonna Fill In
Those blanks for themselves
and uh uh you know I think really it's
just about discussion most of all you
know I do rehearse but for me a valid
rehearsal is just as much just sitting
over dinner and just talking about where
we think this character has been and
what we think they want all those things
as a writer you do
um where the characters going and
um we just sort of discuss different
approaches and uh so you know hopefully
by the time you start shooting you have
answered each other's questions about
the direction of this character how this
character is going to become you know
come to life on screen and so you know
from there I don't tend to do
heavy blocking rehearsals like she knew
met famously rehearses for two weeks
like a play you know marks out the
locations the props you know furniture
and he has the actors go through every
scene start to finish like a play and
that works great for him and obviously
you know soon the movies are fantastic
um I don't want to
pin it down that much and also I've
rarely had the luxury of time I mean you
know I'm trying to make a sound like
I've made a choice about the rehearsal
but really it's mostly because I only
get a couple of days tops and I want to
rehearse with the yeah I don't really do
we do like a table read with everybody
but then I want to break them up into
groups
um and and just kind of work more
intimately with them uh and so you know
a lot of this discussion and how to
um what what the big moments are in the
script uh we'd like to talk about a
little bit about the scenes with the
actors and I like to ask them questions
um I like to instead of coming in and
saying well here's what I think about
this character I think this guy I like
to say well what do you think you're
after in the scene
you know and I like to say what do you
think is the most important thing you
say in the scene
and I learn a lot from that because
oftentimes it's not what I think at all
but it's better than what I thought or
just different in a way that I can say
this is where he's going to go with that
that's great
um so I I tend to now just be much more
interested in what the actor feels about
it uh and and what their take is on
where a scene is going to go or uh and
you know just getting off the your the
topic of your question for a bit but
just another casting you know it's so
important because of this process to
cast that right actor you know and and
you're the old joke it's 50 direct job
whatever it is but it's it's like 90 of
the director's job you get that right
actor in that role
um because it's not my job as a director
to teach someone how to act or to teach
them how to be in this role
um they got to come with their game and
they're gonna they're gonna play to win
and so you've got to be sure that that
actor is is sees it the way you do and
is going to give you what you what the
what the role needs because if not you
know you really can't reasonably expect
the actor to completely okay no I need
you this is all wrong it'll come come at
this from a completely different
direction
that's rarely going to work you know
most actors are just not going to
respond to that and so you're sort of
stuck with what what their
interpretation so casting most important
thing in the world to do
and with this back story that you would
prepare it sounds like a lot of it maybe
the audience wasn't even privy to some
of what it was the most none of it you
know it's really just about even the
actor a sense of uh their own context
but I don't do it anymore like I said
because it's just the actors kind of do
for themselves and I don't want them to
feel like I'm imposing this idea on them
you know if they need something for me
they know they can come to me and say
what do you think you know then that's
that's great but for the most part uh I
I trust them to you know feed them their
characters out
what's your process for reading a
screenplay that someone else wrote
um you know I try to imagine myself as
the viewer
um and uh yeah I try just to clear my
mind of all the things that I know about
how movies are made and just try to
concentrate on the story and the
characters I usually have to read a
script twice to really get it
um uh and if I if I choose to do it then
you know many more times
but sometimes I'm more able to
find flaws in other people's scripts
than in my own
so I can so a friend of mine gives me a
script to read I can give him fantastic
notes and feedback but I can't do it on
my own script I have to have somebody
else okay and tell me where I've gone
wrong there's a strange blindness that
you get
what's the wrong way for a director to
read a screenplay
I guess you know I mean there's probably
a couple of wrong ways but uh
the the first one way is to read it like
a person in the film business
you know you want to try to read it like
an audience which is difficult because
it's got nomenclature and technology and
then you know words of technical stuff
in it that doesn't make it feel like
it's a reader-friendly experience
but um The Challenge I think is to try
to just forget everything you know and
read this thing and just have a visceral
emotional reaction to it do I feel for
these characters do I want to tell the
story do I want to find out what happens
after this is over
those are the kinds of correct things uh
you know to bring to it so I guess uh
the incorrect things are you know just
if you're too conscious of the process
that's a big scene man how am I going to
do that that's like a thousand extras
you know they're gonna give you the
money to do that you know I'm gonna need
a crane here you know that's for later
um you just want to try to you can do I
connect with this on any kind of human
level you know do I care about these
people
so then the latter is how someone in the
industry would an industry read would go
instead of yeah for lack of a better
term I realized this sounds very woo-woo
but a heart read I guess so yeah yeah
that's a good way to put it that's you
know it really is you you hope when I
write a script I I use very few
technical terms uh I make it very spare
uh my paragraphs no more than four lines
each and I never I open up a script and
I see a paragraph this long oh God it's
a dense it's hard to read so I try to
make everything spare reader friendly
and I try to be careful not to ever
describe something that can't be
photographed
you know I don't like to say you know
this character he walks in the room and
uh she feels totally out of place
what does that mean you know what's the
behavior that tells us she feels solely
out of place is she checking yourself in
the mirror a little bit dude that's the
kind of thing I want to put in my script
and not just leave or directly to figure
out like how direct is going to be me so
I especially don't want to have to you
know figure that out so that's the way I
always tell writers you know just don't
write something you can't photograph
and um so hopefully if someone reads my
script they're not going to be too
bogged down in shots and all the
technical stuff that gets in the way of
the storytelling in that format